monsieur blanc remercie d'être en direct
avec nous vous êtes donc un député la
république en mars comment avez vous
accueilli cette nouvelle
écoutez je leur serai surtout comme
étant la résultante d'une différence
d'appréciation stratégique
c'est pas tant sur la question des
valeurs selon moi des sujets qui se
posent à la france aujourd'hui ea et à
son gouvernement parce que je pense
effectivement que il a sans doute besoin
de de rééquilibrer certains volets de la
politique qui a été conduite jusqu'à
présent et attendent là il ya deux
stratégies mais on peut se situer de
l'extérieur et créer un groupe
parlementaire autonome on te fait un
choix celui que j'ai fait de continuer
donc aux parlementaires la république en
marche de plaider de et de faire valoir
son point de vue
donc faisons en sorte qu'il soit entendu
je pense que par souci d'efficacité il y
à davantage de capacités je dirais de
faire évoluer les choses quand on est à
l'intérieur d'un groupe que quand on se
place à l'extérieur
je trouve vraiment si on était en mesure
d'exercer rapport de force important ce
qui est clairement n'est pas le cas
alors bien évidemment c'est ça la
démocratie 1 c'est le débat que chacun
ait une idée la défense pour autant un
parti politique dans un parti politique
ne faut-il pas une certaine unité est ce
que c'est ce qui est en train de perdre
la république en mars
je penche pas parce que vous savez la
république en main je dispose encore
d'un groupe important
elle a des partenaires non je crois
loyaux au travers du modèle travers
d'agir qui ont aussi leurs exigences et
il faut qu'elle conserve la
responsabilité de rassembler au-delà
j'ai pas entendu langue le groupe qui se
créent l'intention de citer dans
l'opposition mais plutôt d'être d'un
apport à la république en marche ont
garé dans une forme d'indépendance et
d'os les deux capacités de manoeuvre
donc pour moi ça peut être aussi un
partenariat à construire de renforcer la
majorité plutôt qu'aux que la
déstabiliser est-ce que c'était
prévisible
cette création de nouveaux groupes
parlementaires on dirait que ça faisait
partie des bruits de couloirs depuis
depuis un certain temps c'est aussi je
pense qu'il faut le recevoir comme ça
comme l'expression d'une sensibilité et
d'une stratégie
encore une fois différente la république
en marche c'est quand même la somme de
sensibilités différentes qui se
réunissent autour d'un programme
il ya des gens brad ya des gens de
gauche c'est le pari qui avait pris
annuel mâcon en 2017 et je pense que
évidemment au fil du temps au fil de
l'expérience au fil de la réalité c'est
aussi des dépositions qui évolue qui se
reforment qui se reconstruise tout
l'exercice d'une majorité question un
exercice difficile on on l'a connu dans
le quinquennat précédent
alors là la république en mars il me
semble que c'etait 316 débuté députés au
départ aujourd'hui 288 selon vous c'est
pas l'expression d'un malaise ça révèle
rien non je pense que ça révèle le souci
d expression de sensibilités différentes
il faut le recevoir comme ça mais ça ne
remet pas en cause la stratégie centrale
de la république en marche qui était
très appuyé sur un rassemblement qui
transcende les appartenances politiques
et qui réunissent des parlementaires qui
réunissent majorité de français autour
d'un programme pour la france
alors la république en mars perd la
majorité absolue quelles conséquences
sans vous je pense que les y aura pas de
conséquence tangible puisque encore une
fois la république en marche s'appuie
d'ores et déjà et depuis
puis j'ai plusieurs mois sur des
partenaires loyaux
ça veut dire par contre qu'il faut
qu'elles soient très attentives à une
tare ces parlementaires pour qu'ils
puissent bien exprimé les préoccupations
les visions qui est la leur et ça on l'a
fait encore ce matin d'ailleurs en rayon
groupe avec comme sujet exclusif la
question du même date réclament comme on
dit et quelque chose si attentive à ses
partenaires de façon à ce que le souci
de rassemblement qui est le sien au
départ reste très actif pour lui
permettre de préserver son influence à
l'assemblée nationale était de soutenir
efficacement gouvernement alors vous
parliez à l'instant d'impact d'un
partenariat avec ce nouveau groupe
parlementaire qui n'a juste d'être créée
comment ce partenariat cette
collaboration peut se concrétiser
écoutez moi j'ai entendu de la part en
tout cas de la forte à de mathieu reçoit
l'un de ceux qui qui qui l'animé qui ont
procédé à sa création
j'ai bien entendu l'intention d'être
dans un rapport constructif à la
majorité d'être d'un apport de réflexion
de propositions ça veut dire
d'amendements pour des parlementaires
donc il nous appartiendra je pense que
de les examiner sérieusement son trait
supposé sectaire pour voir ce qui peut
être retenu ce qui peut correspondre à
la stratégie que nous mêmes développons
pour pouvoir entendre dans les
propositions qui sont créés tout je sais
daigneault partir de l'air d'une
certaine façon ils veulent un député la
république en mars de la 14e
circonscription du rhône où vous étiez
en direct sur rt france marseillais
d'avoir été avec nous